AGO.
THERE ARE THOSE IN OUR PARTY WHO
BELIEVE THAT AS THE PRESIDING
OFFICER OVER THE JOINT SESSION
OF CONGRESS THAT I POSSESS
UNILATERAL AUTHORITY TO REJECT
ELECTORAL COLLEGE VOTES.
I HEARD THIS WEEK THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAID I HAD THE RIGHT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG.
I HAD NO RIGHT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
THE PRESIDENCY BELONGS DO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ALONE.
FRANKLY, THERE'S NO IDEA MORE
UN-AMERICAN THAN THE NOTION THAT
ANY ONE PERSON CAN CHOOSE THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
I HAD NO RIGHT TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF OUR ELECTION.
KA
KAMALA HARRIS WILL HAVE NO RIGHT
TO OVER TURN THE ELECTION WHEN
WE BEAT THEM IN 2024.
LOOK, I UNDERSTAND THE
DISAPPOINTMENT MANY FEEL ABOUT
THE LAST ELECTION.
I WAS ON THE BALLOT.
WHATEVER THE FUTURE HOLDS, I
KNOW WE DID OUR DUTY THAT DAY.
JOHN QUINCY ADAMS REMINDS US
DUTY IS OURS.
RESULTS ARE GONE AND THE TRUTH
IS THERE'S MORE AT STAKE THAN
OUR PARTY OR POLITICAL FORTUNES.
MEN AND WOMEN IF WE LOSE FAITH
IN CONSTITUTION, WE WON'T JUST
LOSE ELECTIONS, WE'LL LOSE OUR
COUNTRY.
>> WELL, THAT WAS MONUMENTAL.
>> THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
SAYING SOMETHING WE HAVE NOT
HEARD HIM SAY BEFORE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG.
I HAD NO RIGHT TO OVER TURN THE
ELECTION.
>> WE HAVE NOT HEARD, AS YOU
SAID, VICE PRESIDENT PENCE SPEAK
THIS STRONGLY ABOUT -- WE KNOW
THAT HE HAS AT ONE TIME WHAT HE
CONSIDERED A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HE
RARELY SPEAKS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
TO HEAR HIM SAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS WRONG, IT WAS ALSO
INTERESTING THE SETTING.
THE FEDERALEST SOCIETY.
THEY DIDN'T BOO.
THERE WAS SILENCE BUT THEY WERE
APPLAUDING HIM AT OTHER PARTS
WHERE HE'S TALKING ABOUT HIS
ALLEGIANCE TO THE CONSTITUTION.
>> HE SAID KAMALA HARRIS WILL
HAVE NO RIGHT TO OVER TURN WHEN
WE BEAT THEM IN 2024.
I'D LOVE TO KNOW SOME COLOR
INSIDE THE ROOM WHAT THE
REACTION WAS WHEN THEY HEARD
THAT FROM THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT.
LET'S BRING IN CNN CHIEF
POLITICAL ANALYST GLORIA BORGER.
HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF DEFENDING
DEMOCRACY TOGETHER AND CNN
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR.
DP
GLORIA, NOW HEARING THIS 13
MONTHS AFTER THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE HAD THE
RIGHT TO OVER TURN THE ELECTION.
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF HEARING THIS
FROM MIKE PENCE.
>> IT'S ENORMOUS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE
HEARD THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
SAY DIRECTLY THAT HIS FORMER
BOSS WHOM HE SUPPORTED FOR HIS
ENTIRE TERM SAY THE PRESIDENT IS
WRONG.
I HAD NO RIGHT TO DO WHAT HE
WANTED ME TO DO AND SO I DIDN'T
DO IT.
INSTEAD, I ADHERED TO WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION TOLD ME TO DO.
HE USED JUSTICE SCALIA AND SAID
OUR ELECTIONS ARE RUN BY THE
STATE, NOT BY THE CONGRESS.
IT WAS A MORE RECEPTIVE AUDIENCE
AT THE FEDERALIST THAN AMONG
SOME IN THE REPUBLICAN BASE.
I THINK THIS IS A RIFT WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOW BROKEN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE REPAIRED.
HE HAS DECIDED TO GO HIS OWN WAY
AND THE QUESTION I HAVE REALLY
IS WHETHER IT MEANS HE'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO RUN OR WHETHER
IT MEANS HE'S DECIDED NOT TO RUN
AND DOESN'T REALLY HAVE THAT
CONCERN AS MUCH ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN BASE.
WE'LL JUST HAVE TO SEE HOW IT
PLAYS OUT.
IT'S REMARKABLE.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME, THE FIRST
TIME WE HAVE REALLY HEARD THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT SAY
ANYTHING MORE THAN WE DON'T SEE
EYE THE EYE ON THAT DAY.
>> BILL, HE WENT EVEN FURTHER.
HE SAID THE PRESIDENCY BELONGS
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, ALONE.
THERE'S NO IDEA MORE UN-AMERICAN
THAN THE NOTION ANY ONE PERSON
COULD CHOOSE THE PERSON E
AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
BILL, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
MOMENT?
>> I'M GLAD MIKE PENCE SAID IT.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT HE NOW
SAYS.
WILL HE SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP IF
HE IS THE NOMINEE IN 2024.
FOR ME THAT'S THE CORE JUDGMENT.
THE CORE LINE THAT THESE PEOPLE
HAVE TO CROSS OR STOP AT
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU THINK OF
IT.
LIZ CHENEY SAID DONALD TRUMP
CANNOT BE PRESIDENT AGAIN.
IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO SAY
THAT, YOU CAN DISTANCE YOURSELF
AND TRY TO LAY THE DPRGROUND WO
FOR YOUR OWN CAMPAIGN BY MAKING
CLEAR WHAT TRUMP DID WAS NOT
ACCEPTABLE.
YOU CAN TRY TO POSITION YOURSELF
TO ONE NOTCH OF TRUMP.
IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO SAY YOU
WON'T SUPPORT HIM IN 2024, IT'S
ULTIMATELY NOT THAT MEANINGFUL.
>> LET ME READ TWO MORE LINES
FROM THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
AND GET YOUR THOUGHTS.
HE ALSO SAID I ALSO SHARE THE
CONCERNS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ABOUT IRREGULARITIES
IN THE ELECTIONS IN SEVERAL
STATE BUT THOSE
RESOLVE BY OUR COURT AND STATES.
YOUR THOUGHT S ON WHAT WE HEARD
FROM PENCE?
>> THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST
ENORMOUS WINS COMING IN HIS
DIRECTION.
HE'S STANDING UP FOR THE
CONSTITUTION IN A PARTY THAT HAS
ABANDONED IT.
HE IS GIVING HOPE AND LIGHT TO
PEOPLE TO THEIR CAN BE
OPPOSITION TO DEMOCRATS.
WHAT HE'S DOING IS DRAWING A
LINE IN THE SAND SAYING TRUMP
YOU'RE ON ONE SIDE AND I'M ON
THE OTHER.
THAT HAS ENORMOUS CONSEQUENCES
BOTH FOR THE COUNTRY.
IT'S ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT SAYS
THAT ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT.
IT ALSO HAS PERSONAL POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR A MAN WHO
ALWAYS WANTED TO BE PRESIDENT
AND BY ALL ACCOUNTS CONTINUES TO
ASPIRE TO THE PRESIDENCY IN
2024.
BILL CRYSTAL IS RIGHT.
HE HAS TO SAY DONALD TRUMP
DESERVES TO BE NOWHERE NEAR THE
PRESIDENCY.
HE IS ESSENTIALLY JUST DRAWN A
LINE IN THE SAND AND PUT HIMSELF
OPPOSED TO DONALD TRUMP WHICH IS
AS WE ALL KNOW EXACTLY WHERE THE
BASE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS.
THEY ARE WITH TRUMP.
THEY ARE NOT WITH WHAT MIKE
PENCE JUST SAID.
THEY DISAGREE WITH MIKE PENCE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> GO AHEAD, GLORIA.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR MIKE
PENCE POLITICAL FUTURE?
THAT'S WHY I SAY MAYBE HE'S
THINKING ABOUT NOT RUNNING.
WHO KNOWS.
WE HAD THE REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE
VOTE TO CENSURE LIZ CHENEY AND
ADAM KINSINGER AND THEY SAID IT
WAS POLITICAL DISCOURSE BUT THEY
HAVE TRIED TO WALK THAT BACK.
THEY SAID THE PEOPLE PROTESTING
PEACEFULLY WERE DOING POLITICAL
DISCOURSE.
THEY VOTED TO CENSURE THE TWO
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT WHAT MIKE
PENCE SAID.
I THINK BILL IS RIGHT.
YOU WANT TO TAKE THIS A STEP
FURTHER BUT I DO THINK THAT THIS
IS HUGELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE MIKE
PENCE HAS JUST GOTTEN A DIVORCE
FROM DONALD TRUMP.
I MEAN TRUMP HAS BEEN AT HIM
SAYING THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
SHOULD INVESTIGATE THE FORMER
VICE